Researchers have found out that polar bears
have higher metabolisms than previously thought
and are having trouble eating enough food
to keep up their weight in the wild.
Using GPS-enabled collars affixed with videocameras,
researchers watched 9 female polar bears
living in the Beaufort Sea
forage for  food during 3 spring seasons.
They also captured the bears to take blood
and other samples
at the beginning and end of the study.
With these data in hand, they measured how fast
the large carnivores burn calories and
found polar bears need to eat more than
12,000 calories per day minimum.
That means they have to eat at least 1 adult ringed seal
or the equivalent of nearly 220 Big Macs
every 10-12 days.
Bears that killed and ate ringed seals
during the 8-11 day observation periods,
gained or maintained weight, but more than half the
bears lost weight and four lost at least
10% of their body weight.
It turns out polar bears use a lot of energy
when they walk,
more than similarly-sized animals.
What’s more,
the bears they tracked walked a fair amount
more than a quarter of the time.
This is bad news for these bears.
As sea ice continues to collapse,
energy demands may outstrip the bears’ ability to
find food and ultimately lead to their demise.